Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Merhaba, akışta bir değişiklik oldu
ben de böylelikle
daha önce karşınıza çıkabildim.
Çok da iyi oldu,
çünkü bu program bana geldiğinde
ben bu kilit, kapı, pencere,
çatı; bu kurguya baktım ve dedim ki,
"Hımm, Ramis Bey ben bunu bozacağım."
"Nasıl Birep Hanım, niye öyle diyorsunuz?"
Dedim, "Ben genetikçiyim
ve burada genetikten bahsedeceğim.
O zaman kapı, pencere, çatı...
Buna gelinceye kadar
benim bahsedeceğim yer zemin.
Hatta biraz subasmanı da
işin içinde var."
Neden? Çünkü siz bir bina
inşa edeceğiniz zaman,
önce zemin etüdü yaparsınız.
Oraya bir gökdelen mi yapacaksınız,
bir tapınak mı yapacaksınız,
yoksa bir kır kulübesi mi kuracaksınız;
bu sizin mühendislik beceriniz,
hayalleriniz, elinizdeki malzeme kadar
inşa edeceğiniz zeminin
olanaklarıyla da sınırlıdır.
Ben bir genetik bilimciyim.
Biz burada tam olarak da aslında,
bireysel olarak kişilerde
bu zemini araştırıyoruz.
Sabahki konuşmalarda;
sonunda başımıza gelenler,
toplumsal konumumuz,
hayattaki seçimlerimiz,
iş hayatımıza gidildi
ama ben sizi tekrar bunun
başına getirmek istiyorum.
Biz birer biyolojik canlıyız.
Vücudumuzdaki bütün faaliyetler,
bütün duygular aslında bir biyolojik
sürecin sonucunda ortaya çıkıyor.
Ve bizlerin bu sürece
kaynaklık eden bir fabrika ayarı var.
"Genetik" dediğimiz;
kromozomlarla taşınan,
annemizden ve babamızdan bize gelen,
DNA molekülü üzerinde
kodlanan bu fabrika ayarları
bize bir potansiyel getiriyor.
Olabileceğimizin sınırları
ve her zaman karıştırılan bir konu var.
Onu da söylemek istiyorum.
Bu genler, DNA'nın üzerinde
sadece genler yok.
Gen dışında başka fonksiyonu
olan bölümler de var.
Ama bu genler,
her türlü fiziksel ve biyokimyasal
faaliyetimizi bizim düzenliyor.
Ve şöyle düzenliyor;
bazen gerçekten kendi başına,
çok deterministik olarak
"varsa var, yoksa yok"
biçiminde yapıyor bunu.
Nedir, mesela benim parmaklarım eğri.
Bilmiyorum, siz de
kendi parmaklarınıza bakın.
Bu, bir tek gen tarafından
kontrol edilebilen bir özelliktir.
Ve o taşıdığınız gene göre parmaklarınız
ya böyle eğri olur ya düz olur.
Burada artık ne kadar çalışsanız,
kalıplara yatırsanız
değiştirebileceğiniz bir şey yoktur.
Hakikaten bu derecede deterministiktir.
Bunlar bizim "monogenik"
dediğimiz özelliklerdir,
yani tek bir gen tarafından
kontrol edildiği zaman.
Bu arada bir şey söyleyeceğim.
Burada bu kırmızı yuvarlağın
içinde durma kuralı var,
benim için süreyi kısaltmak değil ama
bu kadar küçük bir alanda durmak
biraz zor oluyor,
o yüzden hep kendime
hatırlatmaya çalışıyorum
sınırlarım bu, sınırları aşmayayım diye.
Bu da genetik bir şey bu arada
sınırlarla olan ilişkimiz.
Genellikle ama şöyle oluyor,
birden fazla gen birlikte
bir özellik getiriyor bize.
Şimdi, mutlulukla ilgili konuşulacağını
duymadan önce ben
teknoloji ile ilgili konuşulacağını
duymuştum ve bana dediler ki,
"Sen de yeni bu genom çağı,
kişiselleştirilmiş tıp,
bireye özgü ilaç seçimi,
genetik yatkınlıklarımız...
Bunlardan bahsedecek
bir konuşmaya var mısın?"
"Ah, her zaman varım.
Yani seve seve gelir, konuşurum.
On sekiz değil, iki oturum yapalım,
iki kere konuşurum. Hiç önemli değil."
Sonra dediler ki,
"Ama bir de bizim bir üst
başlığımız var: 'mutluluk'."
Ben de dedim ki,
"Hm, şimdi bu kadar teknolojik bir şey,
ben mutlulukla nasıl bağlayayım."
Bir böyle gittim bizim moleküler psikoloji
kitaplarına falan baktım,
mutluluğu nasıl tarif ediyormuşuz biz.
Klinik olarak tarif ettiğimizde
şöyle tarif ediyormuşuz:
Ağrın olmayacak,
kendini beğeneceksin,
kendini ödüllendireceksin,
kendine "aferin" diyor olacaksın,
kaygın olmayacak
ve beklentin olacak.
Ee, tamam. Sobe!
Sobe değil aslında tam, SODE:
serotonin, oksitosin, dopamin ve endorfin.
Bunlar moleküler haberciler.
Bizim vücudumuzda herhangi bir
duygu durumu uyanması için
bu kimyasal moleküllerin doğru zamanda,
doğru yerde,
doğru miktarda üretilmesi
ve karşılığında bir
cevap yaratabilmesi gerekiyor.
Tahmin edeceğiniz gibi bir genetikçi
size bununla ilgili ne söyleyecek?
Bütün bu molekülleri kodlayan genler var.
Ve bu genlerde taşıdığımız
bir takım varyantlar var.
Kişiye özel
ya da o kişinin ait olduğu topluluğa özel,
ya da o topluluğun
ait olduğu coğrafyaya özel.
Ve bu genlerdeki farklılıklar,
bize bu maddeleri üretmekte,
kullanmakta ve onlarla işimiz bittiğinde
onları ortadan kaldırmakta farklı kılıyor.
Bu farklılık da neyi getiriyor
biliyor musunuz?
Mutluluk, aslında çok kişiye özgü bir şey.
Dolayısıyla da herkes için
aynı mutluluk tarifi,
herkesten aynı biçimde
mutlu olmasını beklemek,
herkesten aynı çoklukta
mutlu olmasını beklemek
başlı başına yanlış.
Yanlış, çünkü bu mümkün değil.
Zemin buna olanak vermiyorsa
bu yapılamayacak.
Ha, peki genetik çok ilerledi;
biz her gene bakıyoruz,
anlamını biliyoruz,
ne yaptığını çözüyoruz.
Ya evet biraz,
ama biraz da daha çok
çözeceğimiz şeyler var.
Dolayısıyla da bir elli sene daha
bana yapacak çok iş var.
Bu güzel bir şey, işimi seviyorum.
Ama bazı genler var ki,
hakikaten ne yaptığını biliyoruz.
Mutlulukla ilintisi var mı, var;
serotonin dedik.
Serotonin bizim...
"Ya şimdi ne isterdim
biliyor musunuz Samet Bey?
Hiçbir şey." dediğimiz an var ya,
işte bize o anı dedirten molekül.
"Ohh" dediğimiz,
kafamızdaki koşuşan tilkilerin durulduğu,
başıma gelecek felaketler nedir,
onları engellemek için
hangi tedbirleri almalıyım,
ayrıca sevdiklerimin
başına gelecek felaketleri de
o sırada nasıl öngörebilirim
ve bunları engellemek için
ne yapmam gerekiyor?
Koşar durur.
Bir türlü doğru dürüst uyuyamayız.
Uyanırız, uyandığımızda
kendimizi dinlenmiş hissetmeyiz.
Bu çok uzarsa,
bu sefer zaten canımız artık harekete
geçmek de istemez.
Serotonin bu.
Oksitosin;
oksitosin bizim sevdiğimiz birinde,
birine sarıldığımızda hissettiğimiz.
Kabul edildiğimiz ve kabul ettiğimiz
o sevgiyi fiziksel temasla,
"Evet, burada" diye tanımlayabildiğimiz.
Dopamin, o da güzel.
"Ben yaptım! Aferin, evet."
"Yürü kızım ya, ne iyisin!"
Kendimizi ödüllendirdiğimiz.
Kendimizi beğendiğimiz.
Endorfinler de,
"Acı yok Rocky,"
herkes bu şeyi bilir.
Acı yok, acıyı daha az hissetmek için.
Acıyı daha az tanımlamak için.
Çünkü her duygu gibi,
aslında acı da bir eşiği olan
ve bir hafızası olan bir duygu.
Ve bazen bazı acılarımız aslında,
ya da bazı ağrılarımız,
aslında fiziksel etkeni
orada olmamasına rağmen
biz onları hissetmeye devam ediyoruz.
Neden, çünkü bir hafızası var.
İşte en temelinde,
genetik olarak biz o zaman sizin
mutlu olabilme potansiyelinizle ilgili
bir genetik panel yapsak,
neye baksak,
bu bahsettiğim moleküllere bakıyorduk.
Zaten bakıyoruz.
Hatta ben yine gelmeden önce
son bir tur araştırdım.
Tabii ki öyle bir tane mutluluk geni yok.
Ooo, o geni buldun, çok iyisin!
Ama bu bahsettiğim tabloyu
tamamlayan genler
ve bu genlerdeki varyantlara bağlı
olarak ortaya çıkan bazı tipler var.
Mesela hepinizin ailesinde vardır
o bir tane gamsız.
Ne olsa, başına ne gelse, dünya yansa
"Amaaan!" der. "Hallederiz."
Sizin orada iki ayağınız bir pabuca
girmiş, yüreğiniz pır pır ağzınızda,
sabahlara kadar uyku uyuyamamışsınız;
gelir dayı,
"Ya kızım olur, hayat. Olur."
İşte bu mesela bir BDNF geni var
onunla ilintili.
Yani bazı durumlarda bunu istiyorsunuz.
Hatta şöyle söyleyeyim.
Bazı ülkelerde,
bu genetik profilleri, yani "mutluluk"
diye tanımladığımız o tabloda
nedir işte, tekrarlayalım:
Ağrıya direnç,
kabul edilme, kendini ödüllendirme,
kaygılanmama.
Bu paneli mesela sporcu adaylarına
yapıyorlar bir takımı kurarken.
Bunlardan hangilerini ben yetmişinci
dakika oyuna sokayım da oyunu döndürsün.
Bir yatkınlık çünkü o.
Yani yeniliyorsun orada, beş gol yemişsin,
adam sanki dakika bir ve bir önceki maçta
1-0 öndeymiş gibi sahaya girebiliyor.
İstersin takımında öyle birisini.
Buna bakılıyor mu?
Evet bakılıyor.
Ama tabii sadece buna bakılmıyor.
Aynı şekilde,
bu moleküllerin doğru çalışmasının
tamamlanması gerekiyor.
Niye?
Şimdi, hiçbir molekül
bizim vücudumuzda böyle çıkıp işte,
"İyi günler, ben çok tatlıyım,
benimle tanışınca
kendinizi çok iyi hissedeceksiniz"
ya da işte,
"Allahın selamıyla geldim!"
falan bir hücreden bir hücreye giremez.
Orada hakikaten çok daha
dikkatli bir kurgu vardır.
Doğru zamanda, doğru yere,
doğru miktarda gidecek,
gerektiği kadar orada kalacak
ve sonra olay yerinden ulaştıracak.
Her şeyin fazlası zarar.
Serotonin dedik; mutluluk, oh rahatlama,
kaygıların dinmesi.
Serotonin Sendromu diye mesela
bir hastalık var.
Eğer vücudunuz
çok fazla serotonin üretirse,
özetini şöyle söyleyeyim;
bir bigânelik geliyor üzerinize.
Yani bir atalet, bir umursamazlık,
ama o neşeli olanı gibi değil.
Neyse, geri dönelim.
Dolayısıyla bu moleküllerin
aynı zamanda kapıcıları var.
Hani maça gittiniz,
mesela buraya gelirken gördünüz.
Süper bir stadyum yapmış Bursalılar.
Ama ben mesela buraya bir deplasman
seyircisi olarak geleceğim.
Bana ayrılmış bir gişe var.
Sadece oradan girebiliyorum.
Oraya giderken de biletimi göstereceğim.
İşte bunu yapan bir molekül var vücutta.
Sonra bir de orada bir gişe görevlisi var,
hani akıllı kart bile olsa onu okuyan.
Vücutta da aynı şekilde işliyor sistem.
Dolayısıyla da,
sizin sadece bu molekülleri
doğru üretmeniz yetmiyor.
Üzerine; onları alacaksınız,
doğru yere taşıyacaksınız
ve doğru biçimde
hücrenin içine sokacaksınız.
Çok biyokimyasal
bir mutluluk tarifi oldu değil mi?
Ama niye böyle?
En başına dönelim.
Bizler biyolojik canlılarız.
Bir kere en büyük yanılgıyı kendimize
bir tanecik, çok özel, daha önce
bizim ailemizin başına gelmiş olanlardan,
onların yaşadığı tecrübelerden,
onların seçimlerinden
bağımsız tanımlamamız.
Bu, biyolojik olarak yanlış.
Şuradaki sorulardan birinin cevabı.
DNA'nın hafızası var mı?
Evet, var.
Çok enteresan;
bu bilgisayardaki linear kod gibi,
DNA'da da bizim bilgi,
fonksiyon ile ilgili ya da yapıyla ilgili
bilgiyi sakladığımız bir linear kod var.
Ama hayat çok değişken.
Her an başımıza bir şey gelebiliyor;
bazen bir gök taşı düşüyor,
bazen bir zehirli kimyasal salgılanıyor,
bazen de namert, düşman geliyor
ve bize saldırıyor.
Ve vücut buna şöyle cevap veriyor,
"Hayatta kalmakla ilgili yaşadığın
bu travmanın ben tecrübesini,
asıl kodu bozmadan aktarmalıyım
soyumun diğer temsilcilerine ki
onlar da hayatta kalmakla ilgili
bu bilgiye sahip olsunlar."
Ve bu moleküler düzeyde yapılıyor.
Metil grubu diye bir
kimyasal molekül yapı var CH3,
neyse bunu DNA'nın üzerine
çentik gibi takıyorsunuz.
O yüzden,
bizim bazı anılarımız aslında bizim değil.
Bizim bazı fobilerimiz,
aslında bizim değil.
Bizim bazı travmalarımız,
Bu, soyumuzun hikâyesi ile ilgili.
Onların hayatta kalmak için
verdikleri mücadelede,
başlarına gelmiş olan olaylarla ilgili.
Ve bunu biz artık
moleküler düzeyde çözebiliyoruz.
Daha güzeli, eğer siz bu mevcut hayatta
doğru beslenirseniz,
doğru spor yaparsanız,
inanırsanız, tabii benim haddime değil
neye inanacağınızı söylemek,
ama herhangi bir şeye inanırsanız,
o inançla ilgili
bir ritüeli takip ederseniz,
bütün moleküler araştırmalar
gösteriyor ki,
bu mevcut olan çentiklenmiş geninizi
başka türlü kullanmaya
başlayabiliyorsunuz.
Yani hafızanızdan gelen,
zamanında hayatta kalmakla ilgili önemli
ama belki bu hayatta artık sizin önünüzde
engel olan o anıyla barışıp,
özgürleşip yolunuza devam edebiliyorsunuz.
Aynı şekilde,
bu hafıza size yediklerinizle
olan ilişkiyi anlatıyor, ama şöyle;
hani ne yerseniz osunuz, diyorlar ya
büyükannenizi büyükbabanız
ne yediyse asıl osunuz.
Olay yine biraz daha geriye gidiyor.
Çünkü bu moleküler çentikler,
kuşaktan kuşağa aktarılıyor.
O yüzden sizin yaptığınız tercihler
bugün sizinle ilgili bir şeyi
değiştirebileceği gibi,
üstüne üstlük daha sonra da
sizin çocukların, torunların hayatını
daha güzel yapabilir.
Daha iyi yapabilir.
Daha az ağrılı yapabilir.
Yani genetik kaderimizde
seçimlerimizin rolüne en basiti burada.
Bu DNA size bir potansiyel getiriyor,
o potansiyeli ne yönde kullanacağınız
sizin bireysel tercihlerinizle
şekilleniyor.
Bazen şekillenemiyor, tamam.
Ama çoklukla şekilleniyor.
Peki Küçük Prens'in mutluluk tercihi
genlerinde mi gizliydi?
Muhtemelen öyleydi,
yani ben Küçük Prens'in
hikâyesine baktığımda
böyle her şeyi olumlayan,
kötü şeyler yokmuş gibi
davranan bir tip görmüyorum.
Seven, sevgisi için
zaman emek harcamaya razı,
kötü olayların kötü olduğunu bilen,
ama onları da bir tür
tevekkülle karşılayan bir tip.
Yani derim ki ben onun için,
muhtemelen serotonin reseptörü
doğru çalışıyormuş.
Ama siz tabii bunları,
tabii on sekiz dakikanın içinde
size anlattıklarımı bir yere koyamazsınız,
ama bunun için ben size
küçük bir yol önereceğim naçizane.
Bunu hep söylerim.
Genetikte ilk genetik test,
ilk genetik araştırma, yoklama
aslında aile hikâyesidir.
En başında da ne dedik:
ağrı olmasın, kaygı olmasın,
sevildiğimizden emin olalım,
beklentimiz olsun.
Toplayın ailenizi bir araya,
oturtun,
aile büyüklerine anlattırın;
neler oldu, kimin başına ne geldi,
sizin hiç tanımadığınız
bir dayınız mı vardı acaba
futbol oynarken aniden yığıldı kaldı
ve şimdi bu çok acıklı bir hikâye olduğu
için size bundan bahsetmiyorlar.
Kayıp kardeşiniz mi var,
zamanında atalarınız
bir yerden bir yere mi göçmüş,
o esnada büyük kayıplar mı vermiş?
İnanın hem çok zevkli bir şey
aileyle vakit geçirmek,
artı biliyorsunuz,
büyükler özellikle yaşları ilerlediğinde
anlatmayı seviyorlar.
Sizin dinlemeye hazır olmanız,
onları da kendini iyi hissettirecektir
ve böylelikle karşılıklı
bir mutluluk olacak.
Bu hikâyeyi bir kenara not edin.
Çünkü siz, varlığınız,
bugünkü biyolojik varlığınız
aslında sizin soyunuzun
varlık zincirinde temsili olarak
tezahür etmiş, halka olma haliniz.
Zincirin başını da tanıyın.
Oradan zaten kendi mutluluğunuzla ilgili
genetik ipuçlarını dahi
göreceksiniz diye düşünüyorum.
Süreyle ilgili, çok da ağır
davranmadığımı umut ediyorum,
teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)